estos afganos se han visto obligados a
regresar a su país la organización
internacional para las migraciones en el
paso fronterizo de islámica la lista la
bienvenida las personas que ven han sido
expulsadas por la república islámica de
irán fueron detenidos en la calle en su
lugar de trabajo mientras cruzaban la
frontera por eso no tienen equipaje
cada semana unos dos mil refugiados
afganos con un estatus migratorio
irregular son deportados por irán
algunos incluso tienen dificultades para
caminar correctamente
estuve allí dos años en los cuales 15
meses los pasé en prisión ayer me
golpearon con palos y luego me
expulsaron mi cuerpo está cubierto de
moretones los tengo por todas partes
desde la espalda hasta los pies recibí
100 golpes al
a liam a qurbani fue acusado de haber
participado en una reyerta nos muestra
su cuerpo magullado como prueba de la
violencia ejercida contra los afganos en
las cárceles y centros de detención
iraníes
en los pueblos de la provincia de herat
casi todas las familias tienen un hijo
que se ha ido a trabajar a irán a menudo
de forma ilegal el hijo de este
fabricante de ladrillos fue asesinado
por los guardias fronterizos iraníes
de arak la gente me contó cómo murió mi
hijo yo no lo vi estaba entre la gente
que cruzaba la frontera se escondía pero
mi hijo se levantó y corrió para escapar
le dispararon en la pierna y la bala
viajó hasta el riñón afganistán está
sumido en una grave crisis económica
cada día hay más afganos dispuestos a
correr el riesgo
mi hijo tiene 6 años está débil y
discapacitado he gastado mucho dinero en
su atención médica pero no crece tras
siete intentos fallidos este padre
desempleado y endeudado quiere volver a
salir
tengo que ir a irán
no tengo otra opción aquí nadie nos
ayuda tengo que cuidar de mi hijo desde
que los talibanes tomaron el poder hace
nueve meses al menos un millón de
afganos han huido al país de los
ayatolás